[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing dumbledore severus snape
and snape's stint as headmaster of
hogwarts in the following except from
the deathly hallows
we witnessed snape's unusual choice of
password for his study
harry ran without stopping clutching the
crystal flask of snape's last thoughts
and he did not slow down until he
reached the stone gargoyle guarding the
headmaster's office
password dumbledore said harry without
thinking
because it was he whom he yearned to see
and to his surprise the gargoyle slid
aside
revealing the spiral staircase behind
the question is
why on earth would snape choose a
password like dumbledore
if snape wanted to keep his office
secure then surely the name of former
headmaster is the worst possible choice
it would almost be anyone's first guess
it's like choosing
a password like password or one two
three
at this stage snape's cover was secure
the death eaters were sure that they had
an ally in snape
which makes it even more unusual that
his choice of password would be the
figurehead against the forces of
voldemort
while it's possible that snape never
brought any of the death eaters to his
office
i think that this is unlikely the cairos
were teaching at the school during his
tenure
and i'm almost positive that voldemort
would have visited snape in his office
at some point from the deathly hallows
and now
everything was cool and dark the sun was
barely visible over the horizon
as he glided alongside snape up through
the grounds
towards the lake i shall join you in the
castle shortly
he said in his high cold voice leave me
now
one theory for why snape would have
chosen the password dumbledore is that
it was an indicator and reminder of a
fallen
enemy snape telling voldemort that the
password is dumbledore
would be a reminder of what they had
accomplished marking their territory in
a way that was humiliating to the
conquered former
headmaster a form of posthumous
disrespect
it's exactly the type of thing that
voldemort and the death eaters would
derive pleasure from
the password was never really meant to
function as a security measure
and was more of a symbol or formality
anyone who was forced to utter the
password
would be given a not so subtle reminder
of who was defeated in order to assume
the position
another possibility is that dumbledore
was never the password at all
we know that the gargoyle guarding the
headmaster's office is cognizant of who
is trying to enter
this is supported by the fact that
umbridge was refused entry while she was
acting as school headmistress
the fat friar told me he dropped his
voice conspiratorially
so that harry ron and hermione had to
lean closer to him to hear
that umbridge tried to get back into his
office last night after they'd searched
the castle and grounds for him
couldn't get past the gargoyle the
headmaster's office had sealed itself
against her
only smoked apparently she had a right
little tantrum in a magical world it's
reasonable to assume that methods of
security are more advanced
and perhaps change dynamically according
to who it is that is actually trying to
enter
with that being said it's entirely
possible that dumbledore
was a password that was entirely
specific to harry where dumbledore may
not have worked for someone else as a
password
it would work for harry given the
gargoyle's high level of awareness
i think that more dynamic password makes
the most sense perhaps the password
isn't significant at all and it's more
about worthiness of entry
this would explain why umbridge was
never permitted into the office
what do you guys think why would snape
set the password to dumbledore
did he even set the password let us know
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
harry